okay today I'm going to talk to you
about electromagnetic induction now all
of that electromagnetic induction
basically means is being able to
generate an alternating current using a
moving magnet so whenever we have a
magnet moving within a coil of wire so
I'll show you how this works now imagine
we have a coal power station so in a
core power station there's my burning
coals and those burning coals turn water
into steam and that steam turns this
turbine now whenever we have a turbine
turning in order to generate electricity
so that could be coal nuclear
hydroelectric wind power whenever we
have a turbine this is the process
that's going on that turbine is
connected to this part here which is a
generator this generates the electricity
and in order to do that what we need is
a magnet moving within a coil of wire
now this magnet would actually be really
kind of inside this coil of wire but
I've just drawn it like this so I can
see what's going on so what happens is
as the turbine turns it also causes this
magnet here to rotate as well so this
magnet will be turning round and round
and round now whenever we have the
movement of a magnet within a coil of
wire we create an alternating current an
alternating current so if I were to just
draw a graph to show this type of
current it looks like this now the
reason why we generates an alternating
current or AC is because the poles of
this magnet are constantly switching
around north south north south as it
goes so as a result the electrons keep
on flowing in different directions we
establish an alternating current
now there's three things which can
affect the size of the current that we
induce one of them is the number of
turns so if we have loads and loads and
loads of turns of wire on this
get a coil here so loads and loads and
loads and loads of wire wrap to wrap
around round round around we will make
more current we will induce a bigger
current the second thing is a speed of
movement so again if our magnet is being
is moving at a higher speed is rotating
at higher speed we will create again
induce a bigger current and the final
one is the strength of the magnet so the
stronger the magnet is the stronger the
magnet is the bigger the current that
we're going to induce so that
essentially is electromagnetic induction
being able to utilize the movement of a
magnet within a coil of wire in order to
produce an alternating current just as a
side point I just want to show you the
difference between alternating current
and direct current a good example of
something which produces direct current
is a battery because in a battery the
electrons only flow in a single
direction the graph of direct current
looks quite different so there's my axis
direct current is just like that because
the electrons just flow in one direction
so just remember in electromagnetic
induction whenever we use a turbine it
produces alternating currents not direct
current because the poles of those
magnets are constantly constantly
switching round so as a result the
electrons are constantly flowing in
different directions this is how
electricity is generated for any type of
power plant that has a turbine as part
of its mechanism this part right here
with the magnet and the coil of wire
this is what is inside a generator thank
you